Tesla's breaking into the trucking
industry last night
the automaker unveiled its new electric
semi-truck it plans to release it in
2019
Tesla already faces challenges when it
comes to delivering its most affordable
vehicle climb a duty a of art streaming
network cbsn is here with whether Tesla
can meet its new goal
go ahead good morning good morning
founder Elon Musk hasn't said what this
truck will cost but he says it will be
cheaper to operate than a standard
diesel truck this latest unveiling
raises questions about whether Tesla can
keep up with its founders ambition with
the pomp and circumstance of a big tech
unveiling Elon Musk showed off Tesla's
new electric semi-truck unlike any truck
that you've ever driven the CEO says the
semi has a 500 mile range on a single
charge and contains many of Tesla's
signature features including the
autopilot system to meet the man Tesla
says it's building a network of
solar-powered mega charging stations
which need to be ready when the truck
becomes available in 2019 but the
announcement comes as Tesla faces major
challenges it lost a record 619 million
dollars last quarter and has struggled
with production but you will not be able
to buy a better car for $35,000 it is
significantly behind on orders for its
low cost sedan the model 3 with some
customers waiting 18 months or longer
for delivery CNET's Tim Stevens attended
last night's event and says production
is one of the issues
Tesla needs to address they're really
struggling to get those out the door and
to meet all the pre-orders that they
have right now they need to get those
out and they need to get that revenue
flowing to pay for products like the
Tesla sending Stevens also says the
automaker needs to shake the reputation
that some of its vehicles aren't always
reliable when you're talking about a
commercial truck that businesses will
depend upon you need those things to be
absolutely bulletproof those Tesla's
gonna have to absolutely prove to the
industry that their trucks will be even
more reliable than the trucks that are
already in the market today Tesla has
said those reliability concerns are out
of step with current reality as the
company is constantly making
improvements to its cars at the end of
the event must unveiled one other
surprise for the audience he showed off
the Tesla Roadster everybody here at the
table is mouths gape it's an electric
vehicle they say can reach 60 miles per
hour
in just 1 point 9 seconds the cards base
price though $200,000 for a car it
doesn't have like seat from the back
seats 4.4 yeah and get this 0 to 100 in
4.2 seconds yeah where are you going
yeah places Gail doesn't may have some
bumps along the road but I love how Elon
Musk thinks he's always thinking outside
the box yeah and about the future this
roadster available for Christmas yes
four of us can go for a ride with
Charlie no again this good Thank You
Vlad I can hit that boy to drink maybe